To scale something is to make it larger or smaller. This operation is somewhat
different than translation and rotation. When we translate or rotate an object,
we don't change it's shape or it's volume. These two operations are what is
called, rigid body transforms. The name rigid body is just what it says. If you
have an object and apply any number of rotations and translations to it you
won't change its shape. It's as if the object is made out of something, well,
rigid and will keep it's form. Scaling does change an object's overall size, so
it's not a rigid body transform. Scaling in 3 JS is simple enough. Just as
there's a translation or rotation parameter on the object, there is also a scale
parameter. Here's the code to make a balloon object 3 times as large as it was
before. Note that unlike real life. This makes the balloon 3 times larger in all
ways. The thickness of the skin, the part where you seal it off, and so on. Like
rotation, scaling is done with respect to an origin. Since the valve of the
balloon is at the origin, the valve will stay still and the balloon will expand
upwards. In fact, you can scale an object differently along each of the three
axes, x, y, and z. This code is scaling the object along the y axis, but not the
other two. A number less than 1 means you're making the object smaller. The
scale shown here has the effect of compressing it along the y axis. When you
scale a object the same amount in all directions, like we did with the balloon,
this is called uniform scaling. If the scale varies it's called non-uniform
scaling. Uniform scaling does not change any angles within the model itself. Non
uniform scaling can modify angles. In other words, the shape of the model itself
is changed.